russia has historically been
europeans union's largest gas supplier
european energy is closely linked to the
conflict in ukraine here's why
everybody now is watching what type of
sanctions could hit russia if russia
really decides to invade ukraine russia
could retaliate using energy and
actually about a third of all gaps that
europe consumes comes from russia
nowadays so this has traders and
analysts on edge and vanessa says they
see three possible scenarios of what can
happen to european energy in case of
russia invading ukraine
the first one is the most positive in
which russia doesn't cut supplies to
europe europe keeps having a mild winter
and lng vessels keep arriving at
european ports which has so far helped
europe overcome its huge energy crisis
the second scenario would be a more
negative one in which we would see
russia cutting supplies
but europe would still keep having a
mild winter meaning that demand for
natural gas used in heating would be
limited the worst case scenario is the
one in which russia cuts supplies to
europe and europe has a cold spell
meaning heating demand would increase
while supplies would lower that would be
the worst situation europe could face
which could end up with drastic low
levels of european gas supplies causing
real problems to energy markets
but how likely is russia to just go
ahead and cut supplies to europe so most
people i talk to
find it very unlikely that russia could
really cut all energy supplies
even in the case of a potential war that
could hurt russia's image and reputation
as a reliable partner
would make euro to
strengthen in just diversifying its
energy supplies away from russia and
everybody know is obviously
looking and considering what are the
options
that could actually make europe more
independent
from these geopolitical tensions that
can emerge really anytime a question
that some analysts answer by saying
europe has no alternative that the
volume of gas the eu needs can't be
replaced by one supplier without
redistributing deliveries to other
regions so it would require a massive
effort from a number of suppliers to
diversify europe's energy dependence
a good example of why this is
complicated is by looking at the way us
is supplying lng gas to europe and
together with other nations it's helping
displace dependence on russia but even
that measure isn't guaranteed to last
if china's appetite for gas reawakens
those lng tankers will quickly abandon
europe and head eastward so diversifying
is not easy
we are already experiencing
high natural gas and electricity prices
all over the world especially in europe
and we are seeing already inflation
rates accelerating
industrial production
being reduced we're seeing tensions
escalating between ukraine and russia
that all can mean this crisis can get
even worse
[Music]